je vais m'affecter sur la carte d'appel
239 nous roulons dans un véhicule de la
cetam en montérégie au volant charles
martin cet amour est ce qu'on appelle
dans le milieu un paramédic
communautaire intégrée pour qu'on s'en
vost monsieur qui est une sonde urinaire
qui était connu pour
cancer de la fièvre
charles martin est l'un des instigateurs
du projet de parra médecine
communautaire du sis de la montérégie
centre comme l'appelle est classé non
urgents par la centrale de répartition
qu'il se présente seul chez le
septuagénaire qui vient d'appeler le
dauphin l'objectif offrir un service de
soins à domicile pour les personnes
âgées de 50 ans et plus au lieu de les
envoyer automatiquement leur chance on
va commencer par vous évaluez de base
nous entrons à l'intérieur d'une
résidence où habite un couple charles
martel procède à une première évaluation
il saura rapidement s'il doit faire
venir une ambulance ou pas une panoplie
de choses qu'on peut essayer de faire
avant de se rendre à l'urgence le
paramédic essaie de garder les gens dans
le confort de leur maison pour recevoir
des soins préhospitaliers quand la
situation le permet c'est le cas de ce
couple qui veut éviter de se rendre à
l'urgence
monsieur probablement en infection
urinaire actuellement il n'y pas
thermique 39,3 une infirmière de garde
est jumelé au programme le paramédic la
contacter pour valider ces observations
depuis 12 mois la parra médecine
communautaire a permis de désengorger le
réseau de la santé en écartant les cas
non urgents
donc c'est de répondre à un besoin qu'on
voyait sur le terrain auquel on pouvait
pour répondre avant ce projet là parce
que dans la loi quand vous appeler une
ambulance une forme l'ambiance bien chez
vous et on vous transporte à l'hôpital
c'est un automatisme
pour le directeur général adjoint le
projet est une révolution
selon un sondage commandé par le 6 98%
des quelques 500 patients qui en ont
bénéficié cette année se sont dits
satisfaits de ce nouveau service
c'est très prometteur comme comme projet
et ça évite justement aux patients de
subir une visite à l'urgence quand ce
n'est pas nécessaire
le sis de la montérégie centre qui est
le principal partenaire veut maintenant
élargir l'accès à ce projet il y a déjà
des communications avec les six ponts
tjs et les six montérégie ouest pour
voir la faisabilité de l'implanter de
l'est tentent aussi dans leur territoire
parce que le transport par ambulance
fait partie de la réalité
même dans des cas qui semble non urgents
ici pascal robidas radio-canada à
brossard